Today, the Olympic Games are held every four years in a different country.
It's an opportunity for the world's top athletes...
...to test their skills and determination in individual or team sports.
They compete for the Olympic gold medals, which only winners can receive.
To understand the modern Olympics better, we must return to the origin of the Games:...
...Greece.
For the ancient Greeks, the Olympic Games represented the highest form of physical achievement.
The Games were a mix of athletic skill and religion.
They were celebrated in a festival dedicated to the Greek god Zeus.
The Olympics were also a time of political calm.
During the Olympic Games, there was peace across the land.
Athletes traveled from all over the ancient Greek world to compete in beautiful green Olympia.
According to legend, a runner named Coroebus was the first Olympic champion in 776 B.C.
He was a cook who defeated all other competitors in a footrace.
Footraces were central events in the ancient Games at the time.
Men competed with no shoes or clothes.
They were covered only in olive oil as they ran down a straight path...
...in front of a crowd of up to 40,000 people.
Over the centuries, the competitions became more serious.
Olympic rules required athletes to train for at least ten months before the big event.
They then had to train with expert judges for the 30 days before they competed.
Being able to run fast continued to be important.
But the Games also began to include the five pentathlon sports:...
...discus throwing, javelin throwing, running, long jumping and wrestling.
Most of these are still part of today's decathlon.
Discus throwers competed in much the same way as now, but their discus was made of stone.
This material was later replaced by metals such as bronze.
Long jumpers at the time used to hold weights in their hands to give them more momentum.
The extra weight helped to push the athletes through the air when they jumped.
Javelin throwing probably came directly from the skills used to hunt animals.
Like today's javelin, the ancient javelin was a pointed wooden stick about the same height as a man.
However, they used to have a special leather finger holder.
This gave the throwers more power, accuracy and distance.